hey kids welcome back to new rockstars
I'm Sam bass you're here with another
installment of my MCU rewatch series
here today with the big boy
The Avengers I'm only here for the
Easter eggs and hidden references that's
what you kids want that's where your big
advance we're dying for quick spoiler
warning for the Avengers comics all of
Marvel's MCU you guys know the Joe let's
get started with comic book Easter eggs
first up the Avengers the name of the
movie the team that we all love they
first appeared in Avengers number one in
1963 their original lineup being poke
Thor Iron Man ant-man
no there was no cap and there was no
black widow or Hawkeye originally also
during this intro we meet the Chitauri
who appeared in the Ultimate Comics back
in Ultimates number 8 in 2002 originally
in the Ultimate Universe for Marvel each
Atari were an alternative to the Scrolls
trying to be distinct but eventually it
became just a totally different species
as the scrolls actually being a very
popular feces of alien in Marvel Comics
that can shape-shift moving forward we
get a lot of fun nods in the intro to
this movie specifically to project
Pegasus who we mentioned in Thor because
that was actually in the post-credits
scene of Thor project Pegasus in the
main Marvel Comics is actually the place
that the government does tests on the
multiverse tries to find dimensional
doorways and such but in this it's just
the joint dark energy mission whatever
that means Sark energy is a real thing
but I'm guessing this just means that
they're gonna be testing the tester act
on different weapons and such we then
see Coulson Nick Fury and the first
appearance in the MCU of Maria Hill one
of my favorite characters Maria Hill
first appeared in comics and New
Avengers number four in 2005 she very
good a hand hand combat she's very
formidable and eventually she works her
way up in shield to beat its head its
leader also since Nick Fury is here I
just wanted to point out that in the
Ultimate Comics he is the one who forms
the Avengers just like in this movie and
it's worth mentioning that because in
the original comic for the Avengers II
fear he's not in it at all actually the
entire team of the Avengers comes
together because of a character named
Rick Joan so we mentioned in The
Incredible Hulk video go check that out
Rick Jones actually pulls all these
heroes together to fight Loki just like
in this movie hooray moving for again
too and Hawkeye gets brainwashed this is
actually a fun nod two hot guys original
character in a comics where he played an
Iron Man villain but eventually he
becomes reformed and he joins the
Avengers with cap Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver
also choosing to be reformed I also just
want to point out dr. Selvig here who is
an original creation for the MCU but he
does eventually join Marvel Comics but
we also find out that he's part of Hydra
see it's like a switch like in the
they did in the comics yay moving
forward to this awesome Black Widow
fight scene the main Russian general
right here is mr. Luke Oh who's actually
a very low-level iron man and black
widow villain from the comics there's
not much to talk about him really but
this scene is awesome let's play a clip
moving forward again to cap in his
little gym playing with a punching bag
this is an awesome scene check out that
file that he's holding on the tesseract
now there's a bunch of redacted parts of
this file that's you know kind of hard
to figure out but one fan Theory online
points out that maybe at the end of this
line right here at the very end see that
- sort of maybe looks like the word
Mephisto i'ma Fisto if you don't know is
basically the devil or a devil like
being in Marvel Comics but he hasn't
shown up in the MCU not yet maybe the
tesseract could open a doorway to hell
maybe they've run into Mephisto or maybe
that's an entirely different word or
this could be a tease altogether or that
could just be a different word but worth
mentioning moving on to our first
appearance of Iron Man and he's finally
in New York originally Iron Man is
always hanging out in New York with all
the New York heroes in the comics but
director Jon Favreau chose to move into
the West Coast it could have a different
feel to these superhero movies I'm a fan
of that and speaking of New York there
was actually supposed to be a nod to
spider-man in this movie originally
there was going to be an Oscorp building
in the skyline of New York City they
even got the go-ahead from Sonny who had
sole ownership of spider-man in films at
the time but the okay kind of came in a
little bit too late after the digital
effects team had built the entire
digital skyline for New York
sadface moving forward to Tony and
pepper hanging out you hear Tony do this
little nod you have reached the life
model decoy of Tony Stark please leave a
message to life model decoys hooray
in the comics they're basically robots
that are undetectable they look just
like humans very scary they originally
appeared in strange tales number 135 in
1965 and they play a very big role in 82
shield season 4 they'd actually make a
very good villain there moving forward
to cap we see our first shot of a Quinn
jet which actually in the comics was
originally designed by Black Panther
they made their first appearance in
Avengers 61 in 1969 also I want to point
out in this movie we get a lot of hints
and nods to the mind stone without it
ever really being mentioned at all
controlling people showing one of Loki's
memories and a few more things but more
on that later trust me it is so cool
but next let's talk about the
Helicarrier which for me seeing this
movie and not knowing much about comics
this was one of the
most moments in the entire movie oh my
goodness when those propellers come out
of the ocean at home but in the comics
they are originally created by Tony
Stark and used by shield in strange
tales number 135 in 1965 oh boy I
actually prefer this set up a bit
actually looking like a aircraft carrier
instead of the comic book version of it
but hey to each his own moving forward
again to these Thor versus Iron Man vs.
cap a little bit fight in the woods when
Thor hits his hammer on to cap shield
this is actually a little bit different
from the comics originally in the comics
cap shield is a mix of vibranium
adamantium in another third element and
then sometimes other things it depends
on who's writing the comic at the time
but usually Thor's hammer can make some
sort of dent into cap shield but not in
the MCU then moving forward again we
hear Tony Stark referred to Nick Fury as
he's the spy as in Nick Fury is the spy
up all spies the head of shield
despite that no one can trust but moving
to phase two that reference gonna come
back to that in a second we see a test
directive bomb which is very similar to
a storyline that actually came after
this movie the Pleasant Hill Avengers
standoff event whereas shield is trying
to use cosmic cubes as a way of creating
some sort of weapon and they ended up
actually creating a sentient Cosmic Cube
that acts as a little girl who's so
scary but moving for again we see
Hawkeye take down a Helicarrier which is
awesome and then eventually you see him
shoot an arrow into a computer right
here which looks to be a hacking arrow
this is a fun nod - Hawkeye having trick
arrows in the comics which actually
comes back later in the movie but more
on that soon coming to Phil Coulson and
is awesome destroyer gun you know this
doesn't really show up in the comics but
eventually Ironman does work with the
Asgardians to make and guru armor guru
being the metal is used to make Thor's
hammer and it looks an awful lot like
the destroyer armor based on this
picture right here we don't get this in
the comics but we get something close to
it maybe eventually we'll get an armor
suit maybe who knows now I do want to
point out that Coulson dying is
something that was original to the MCU
but eventually it actually looks like
the comics copied them in this Deadpool
scene right here also this movie had an
R rating for the longest time because of
Coulson's death scene they eventually
had to kind of do some crafty editing
where you can hear it you don't see too
much I mean it makes sense but I'm glad
they kept the scene because it is heart
breaking then moving forward to the Hulk
waking up in this rubble you see this
man give him purple pants which is of
course and not to be iconic purple pants
to the Hulk always wears in the comics
you guys probably caught that one but
here's a fun nod to the Ultimate
Universe right here with this line we
are not soldiers
we are not soldiers from Tony Stark
because of course he's not a soldier he
just built an awesome suit of armor to
protect himself and those around him and
the people of the world but in the
Ultimate Universe they're kind of
treated more as soldiers then moving
forward to Iron Man and Loki's
confrontation you get the awesome
tagline for the Avengers
Earth's Mightiest Heroes time very cool
but also I wanted to point out right
here Ironman refers to Thor as a demigod
now in the MCU it seems like he's a
full-fledged god right not really a
demigod demigod meaning half mortal half
God right actually when I thought about
this more it kind of seems like a fun
nod to Hercules now air with me for a
second in the comics Hercules
personality is actually closer to Thor's
personality and Thor the dark world so
this could be actually a fun nod to them
eventually adapting that personality for
Thor or maybe is a demigod anyways
moving on and here's one of my favorite
moments for Hawkeye and the entire MCU
when he gets to use his trick arrows
look at that he's clicking through them
on his little bow we're coming to the
end of comic book references guys I'm
very excited for those MCU ones but
really quick we have dimension that's
awesome not to Hulk's catchphrase Oh
smash now winding down to the end of
this film during all those little news
clips seems we actually see a senator at
the very bottom right with the name
pointin which is actually a nod to the
Iron Man villain senator Boyington he's
very small but hey we still got the
reference and then finally Avengers
Tower is born Avengers Tower is actually
a relatively new creation in New
Avengers number 10 in the 2000s I'm a
big fan of it instead of the Avengers
mansion but I kind of hope that we get
the Avengers mansion eventually in these
movies just one just a lone nod to it
that's all I need and then in our first
post credits scene you hear the others
say this to each other
is to good this is actually a fun not to
thanasis character in the comics during
the main Infinity Gauntlet event which
will be the main plot of infinity war
I'm guessing maybe they'll pull some
things from it this story is actually
about Thanos using the Infinity Gauntlet
to try to win death over because he's in
love with this let's talk about those
MCU Easter eggs says oh boy
there are so many and there's a lot of
foreshadowing to future Marvel films
especially in phase 2 I just want to
give one more shout out to the classic
Marvel flipbook opening because I am
such a fan but also notice that we start
inside of the tesseract they're moving
forward to the project Pegasus incident
we hear the phrase phase 2 prototypes
which I'm guessing is a hint to phase 2
of Marvel which was a phrase that was
being used pretty regularly at this
point then moving forward we get a fun
not too Bruce Banner with his gamma
radiation reference nothing harmful low
levels of gamma radiation that can be
harmful and speaking of MCU hints we get
a nod to these space stones true purpose
opening doorways in space yeah the cube
is a doorway to the other end of space
right you could take the user anywhere
they'd like also notice the scepter
taking over people's brains a lot of
people back then had theorized that this
might be the mind some but a lot of
people shut them down because there were
similar colors but haha Joss Whedon was
10 steps ahead of us I did want to point
out this ant boot line right here and
ant has no quarrel with the boot there's
a lot of lines in this movie that come
background which I just love but more on
those in just a second I wanted to point
out and give a shout out to Mark Ruffalo
in his first appearance in the MCU as
Bruce Banner and also there was another
very famous boy who is in the running to
play Bruce Banner in this film and his
name is Joaquin Phoenix they want to
point out in this scene though what
Black Widow says here even helped keep
some other interested parties off your
scent eventually it was revealed that
this is a nod to the leader the leader
was looking for Bruce Banner somewhere
on the earth but I guess I stopped by
shield got captured or he just failed
and gave up and moving forward to the
members of the shield board we see
powers Boothe who doesn't really pop up
in Winter Soldier but he does appear in
agents of shield season 3 as the same
character in Avengers then just want to
point out during this cap and nick fury
scene you hear something about a $10 bet
at this point I doubt I think would
surprise me 10 bucks says you're wrong
this does come back around more on that
in a second I'm moving forward to the
scene with Pepper Potts and Tony Stark
there's a joke
12% give yourself 12% its credit and
then it comes back immediately we were
having a moment I was having 12% of a
moment moving on to one of my favorite
Easter eggs you hear Ironman say this
his first name is agent now this is
actually an easter egg weirdly enough in
the first draft of the Iron Man script
Agent Coulson was just called agent he
wasn't supposed to have a character or a
personality or anything like that but
eventually Jon Favreau and the entire
crew loved Coulson so much that they
actually gave him a personality then
moving forward to an Iron Man is
investigating all those little files
that Coulson's brought them you see this
is all footage from other MCU movies see
the Hulk fight on the campus you see cap
taking down some Hydra agents and you
see Thor then moving forward to the
Quinjet you see Coulson and cap talking
and also talking about replicating the
serum meaning the Hulk because in the
whole movie we find out that Bruce
Banner and his team are trying to
replicate cap Super Soldier Serum but
everything kind of goes wrong and you
get the Hulk I did want to point out
this little line about needing a little
old-fashioned stars and stripes
old fashioned I like that line a lot it
does come back more on that in just a
second let's talk about that scene where
the other and Loki talked I thought the
other was going to be some popular or
very famous character from Marvel Comics
but actually he's an original creation
for the MCU
but anyways remember that $10 bet that I
mentioned earlier you actually see it
laid out right here when cap pays Nick
Fury moving forward to this agent right
here he looks familiar don't he
well we've seen them actually before in
Thor and then again in Winter Soldier
and in agents of shield this is agent
Sitwell who we find out to be a Hydra
agent that means there's a lot of Hydra
agents on this Helicarrier whoa and
let's give a little nod to caps suit
version - this is my least favorite cap
suit I'm gonna be honest but don't judge
me for it let me know your favorite cap
suit in the comments down below and I
just need to point out that a moment
that happened in the Hulk and in Iron
Man 2 happened in this film as well look
at that they're ending a Gatling gun at
innocent people at least they didn't
fire it but hey they were so close and I
want to give a fun nod to there's only
one God and he doesn't dress like that
yeah I'm not really sure if cap is
Christian and that wasn't really
established in Captain America the First
Avenger or I didn't really see that in
any comic research that I did but I
think the line is pre golden and moving
forward - when Loki is trapped on the
Helicarrier you get the payoff of this
joke and boot and it's worth pointing
out that yes you should be watching
agents of shield and you get a payoff
for this line here this ain't a good
weekend I'll fly at a point she's loved
lunch yes fit well had a date with a
girl who was in Portland eventually that
actress is Amy Acker and there is an
episode of it in the first season of
agents of shield
need to point out this joke right here
about the man playing Galaga that man is
playing Galaga thought we wouldn't
notice but we did this was a deliberate
does pay off in a very cool way later in
this movie here's a fun nod to the
Incredible Hulk movie last time I was in
New York I kind of broke Harlem Heat
broke Harlem during his fight with
abomination but moving to the Loki and
Black Widow interrogation scene you hear
Loki mentioned sau Paulo and a hospital
fire now this isn't in the comics and it
hasn't been brought up again so I hope
if we get a Black Widow solo movie this
storyline will be kind of fleshed out
just a little bit and now my favorite
scene in this movie and all the Avengers
are getting at each other's throat in
that
laughs there's a lot of nods to phase 2
a lot of foreshadowing talking about
wrecking Asgard maybe this is a nod to
the Dark Elves eventually attacking in
Thor the dark world and also everyone is
on a list that line is definitely a nod
to Winter Soldier yes now I think yes
notice how the camera eventually lands
on the scepter meaning that the mine
stone might be affecting everyone in
that room even CCAP break into a room
that kind of seems to go against his
code maybe because he's extra paranoid
because the mine stones affecting them
that's probably part of Loki's plan but
moving forward we get a nod to the Hulk
suicide attempt scene that was mentioned
deleted from The Incredible Hulk movie
but the cool Hulk references don't stop
there notice here during his
transformation you see Hulk fall he's
just turning into the big green monster
check out that writing just underneath
him what does that say under pressure
kinda sounds like hold for just a little
bit don't it we get a couple jokes in
this movie that eventually you know
visited again in thor ragnarok like thor
pulling the hammer throw the walls and
the poles and the support structures of
the Helicarrier and Hulk trying to lift
the hammer which eventually gets you
know visit again in age of Ultron but
anyways remember that old fashion line
as I mentioned earlier we actually
revisit it right here it's an old
fashioned notion I feel like this is
kind of a setup or at least a nod to cap
leading the Avengers also quick montage
of them all suiting up because that's
awesome
and speaking of suiting up that armor
that comes flying out of the building to
rescue Iron Man this is the mark 7
version of the armor for the MCU it
doesn't really look like the mark 7
armor in the comics but hey it's still
very cool but anyways let's bring in a
Galago reference back one more time when
iron is actually flying up to the portal
if you were to look at that from the
side it almost looked just like a game
of Galaga and the mothership that we see
get nuked looks just like one of the
Galaga ships here comes one of the
weirder parts of this movie yeah this
waitress that gets a lot of screen time
near the enemy we don't know who she is
well there was this entire scene and
kind of like subplot about cap falling
in love with this waitress that was
entirely cut from this movie and there
was a Stan Lee cameo in this scene so
this would have meant a little bit more
and we see here later on in this movie
but anyways just thought it was worth
mentioning just like it's worth
mentioning the name of those space
whales which I like calling them space
whales but they were titled leviathans
for this movie and they eventually do
make it into the comics but they were an
original creation for this movie then
moving forward to these two cops that
help cap one of those cops does pop up
in the MCU later on or should
say in the past this is actually agent
Sousa that probably led to him getting
that role in ancient Carter they're
moving forward to an Iron Man pops out
of the way laughter blowing it up
pulling a jonah if you will you see him
land outside of the swarm a place that
ends up in the second post-credit scene
but also let's look at those blueprints
for the Avengers Tower oh so cool you
notice that actually all of the Avengers
have their own rooms or maybe levels in
this building that's very sweet of Tony
let's give him a round of applause thank
you so much
and finally it's worth mentioning that
the end credits you actually have to see
all of the weapons of all of the
different Avengers even Nick Fury and
Marie al very fun and this is the second
time that Marvel has given us a tease of
a new character that everyone went whoa
who's that first Nick Fury and now with
Thanos I was excited as a kid I had no
idea with that purple chin band what his
whole deal was and worth mentioning that
the second post-credits scene actually
wasn't a part of the premiere of this
movie it was added way later and
actually all the actors had to come back
to reshoot it and last but not least
guys let's talk about some pop culture
and historical references like how this
is the last paramount Marvel movie that
was distributed eventually all moved
over to Disney also worth mentioning
that Avengers was actually titled
Avengers Assemble in a lot of other
countries because there is another team
of Avengers that is very popular to
check them out also fun not to other
Whedon bits when you see cap knock that
punching bag down and put another one
right back up it kind of seems like a
fun - Buffy who early on actually knocks
down a punching bag but mainly off of
the chain not by just exploding it also
for science nerds let's talk about
iridium which is an actual real
substance that does come from meteorites
and is used to make anti protons they're
moving forward to when Loki just you
know zaps one of those cars and it goes
sliding down the road
it actually was a mistake that ended up
slaying down the road but they kept it
because it looks awesome then a
shout-out to ac/dc with shoot the
thrills the song that Iron Men pumps
through the shield PA system when he
shows up then you get a nod to reindeer
games and guys there are so many
references to things Iron Man's just
like launching these at the screen
constantly then moving forward to win
Thor and Loki are having their
Shakespearean brotherly confrontation on
the top of that mountain we actually
hear a familiar sound this is actually
eventually confirmed by the team who
made this movie that these are Odin's
Ravens who in mythology and in the
comics are his eyes in the other realms
their specific names are huginn and
muninn
then moving forward to Iron Man and
Thor's fight you got a not to
Shakespeare in the Park which is an
actual event then moving forward again
to one of my favorite jokes in this
movie the flying monkeys reference to
Wizard of Oz of course and it's the only
reference the Captain America gets and
I'd like to know how Loki used it to
turn two of the sharpest men I know into
his personal flying monkeys monkeys do
don't understand I do in the notice in
this scene right here Iron Man's t-shirt
or Black Sabbath you aren't familiar
with Black Sabbath they're the ones who
made the song I am Iron Man
what's that song oh it's been in
basically every Iron Man thing forever
and ever and ever they're moving forward
to a fun nod to mythology and to comics
neat bilge snipe builds type you know
huge scaly big antlers you don't have
those don't think so
they are repulsive actually this ended
up being one of Thor's pets and one of
the Avengers cartoons now let's focus on
Loki and black widows interrogation
scene you hear him call Black Widow a
very offensive name if you are from
olden times I'm not going to say it but
here's the clip this is my bargain you
mewling quim hey it's an Avengers movie
it's okay if you want to google what
that means go right ahead but I am NOT
going to say it moving forward to win
Bruce Banner wakes up in that rubble we
see Harry Dean Stanton you hear him ask
are you an alien which is obvious it has
to be a reference to his character in
the Alien franchise ooh worth pointing
out we actually get a joke about Point
Break a year Iron Man refer to Thor's
Point Break and that does end up coming
back in Thor Ragnarok and you get a fun
Lord of the Rings joke here with the
Legolas line new clench up Legolas
here's a deep cut but I was rewashing
The Incredibles recently and I think
this scene were hoaxed running through
the office building straight towards the
Leviathan it seems an awful lot like
when mr. CREB was running through the
office building to take on that big
robot downtown during the climax of the
movie also I'm getting a very serious
watchman vibe with the nuke that's gonna
hit Manhattan very similar to the end of
that comic or movie if you're fan of
that movie finally you get a fun
Pixar not at the end during all the news
reels you see if you check out the top
right there it says file a113 which is a
code that has been used in every Pixar
movie from the dawn of time and if
finish off this breakdown let's give a
shout-out to the Stan Lee cameo it's one
of the smallest ones and all of the MCU
but much appreciate it was a very nice
button at the end of this movie oh
there's so much guys I hope you enjoy
let me know your favorite Easter Egg or
hidden reference in the
down below or if anyone's that I missed
hope they got it in missiny but you'll
let me know here or on Twitter at only
stupid answers yank out the vowels from
stupid and make sure you like this video
subscribe to new rockso's for more
breakdowns make sure you check out new
rock stars news I'm a part of that we
talk about all the current events in the
nerd world again guys I'm Sam basher and
I'll see you next time
[Music]